تتجه المملكه العربيه السعوديه ضمن خطه
اقتصاديه استراتيجيه الى خصخصه قطاعات
اقتصاديه كبرى في البلاد رغم اصرار
الحكومه على المضي قدما في تنفيذ رؤيتها
لعام 2030 والتي دشنها ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان وعلى لائحه المؤسسات
المعروضه المخصصه للتخصيص جزئيا او كليا
مطار الملك خالد الدولي في الرياض ثاني
اكبر المطارات السعوديه رغم تحذير صندوق
النقد الدولي من ان معدل نمو الاقتصاد
السعودي قد يقترب من الصفر هذا العام
الامر الذي قد يترتب عليه كثير من الاعباء
الملقاه على عاتق المواطنين والمستثمرين
ويجعل ما يعرف برؤيه
2030 موضع تساؤل
كبير بعد مضي اكثر من عام على اطلاق
السعوديه لما يعرف برؤيتها التنمويه
2030 التي دشنها ولي العهد السعوديه
الامير محمد بن سلمان والشروع في تطبيق
اكثر بنودها اثاره للجدل ها هو صندوق
النقد الدولي يصدم السعوديين باعلانه ان
معدل نمو اقتصاد بلادهم قد يقترب هذا
العام من الصفر بل انه قد يسجل معدلات
سالبه وفق تقديرات لوكاله بلومبيرج
الاقتصاديه
الامريكيه اكثر من ذلك حذرت تلك المؤسسه
الماليه الدوليه من ان السياسات التي
تستند عليها تلك الرؤ
تفتقر الى العداله التي تضمن لها التاييد
الشعبي المطلوب وتنذر بتفاقم غلاء المعيشه
ورغم ذلك بدا وكان الحكومه السعوديه مصره
على المضي قدما في تنفيذ رؤيتها حيث شرعت
في خصخصه ثله من مشروعات البلاد
الاستراتيجيه الكبرى مثل مطار الملك خالد
الدولي في الرياض ثاني اكبر المطارات
السعوديه قاطبه اكثر من ذلك صدق العاهل
السعودي الملك سلمان على قرار خصخصه
المؤسسات الصحيه في المملكه ذلك في اطار
مساعي البلاد لجمع 200 مليار دولار لسد
العجز المالي للدوله جراء تهاوي اسعار
النفط وبعد ان تبخر اكثر من 200 مليار
دولار من الاحتياطات الماليه
للمملكه هذه التدابير اثارت مخاوف من تخلي
الدوله السعوديه عن دورها التاريخي في دعم
رفاهيه المواطن على صعيد الخدمات الصحيه
والتعليميه والتوظيف وهو الدور الذي طال
ما تكفلت به منذ اكتشاف النفط واستغلاله
في المملكه في ثلاثينيات القرن المنصرم
فتوسع في عمليات الخصخصه قد يفضي الى
تفاقم معدلات البطاله التي وصلت حاليا الى
اكثر من 12% وفق تقديرات رسميه في مجتمع
اكثر من 60% منه من الشباب كما ان من شان
خصخصه القطاع الصحي ان يثير المخاوف من
ارتفاع رسوم الرعايه الصحيه خاصه مع غموض
تفاصيل هذا الامر بما في ذلك الدور الذي
ستلعبه الشركات الخاصه في هذا المجال فيما
يعاني المواطن اصلا من ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه والمياه ومن زياده رسوم وضرائب
مباشره وغير مباشره بعضها لم يسبق له مثيل
ورغم ان رؤيه السعوديه 2030 عاده ما توصف
بانها اكبر خطه اقتصاديه في تاريخ المملكه
الا انه تؤخذ عليها نقاط اساسيه منها انه
لم يجري اصلا طرحها للنقاش المجتمعي قبل
اعلانها وكاله رويترز كشفت في تقرير لها
ان العديد من اخطاب الصناعه والتجاره في
المملكه ابدوا تحفظات كبيره على العديد من
المحاور الرئيسيه لهذه الخطه خاصه ما
يتعلق منها بطرح جزء من اسهم شركه ارامكو
دره تاج القطاع النفطي السعودي للبيع بل
ونقلت الوكاله عن سعوديين تشبيههم التخلي
عن هذه الشركه بقيام مصر ببيع اسهم قناه
السويس للمستعمرين الانجليز قبل الاحتلال
البريطاني لسداد تلال ديونها وقد جاء هذا
التشبيه من خلال اوسام اطلقوها على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي احتجاجا على بيع الشركه
اكثر من ذلك فان الاسواق الماليه العالميه
تطرح تساؤلات جوهريه في هذا الصدد منها هل
ستكون الشفافيه المطلقه والمحاسبه الكامله
ومحاربه الفساد بلا هواده اجزاء اصليه من
الرؤيه السعوديه الجديده وفي مثال على
غياب الشفافيه كشفت وكاله رويترز قبل
الخصاصه عن لغز اختفاء 36 مليار دولار من
الاحتياطات الماليه خلال الاشهر الاربعه
الاولى من العام الحالي في تقرير رفض
المسؤولون السعوديون الاجابه على اسئلته
واخيرا جاءت رؤيه الامير محمد بن سلمان
الاقتصاديه شبه خاليه من الحديث عن اي
اصلاحات سياسيه او اجتماعيه جوهريه يمكن
ان تعادل تفاقم الضغوط والاعباء
الاقتصاديه الجديده التي ستثق كاهل
المواطنين السعوديين الذين يفتقر ما يقرب
من نصفهم الى مسكن خاص يؤويه في اكبر دوله
مصدره ومنتجه للنفط في
العالم لمناقشه اوسع حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من لندن راان ستيجر مدير تحرير مجله
الاقتصاد العالمي والمحاضر في الاقتصاد
السلوكي بجامعه بي بي بي في لندن كما نرحب
بضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو مصطفى عبد السلام
الكاتب الصحفيه والمختص في الشؤون
الاقتصاديه نبدا اولا مع الاستاذ مصطفى
استاذ مصطفى السعوديه دوله منتجه من
كبريات الدول في العالم للبترول لماذا
تلجا الى الخصخصه يعني السعوديه هي اكبر
منتج للنفط في العالم بتسبق روسيا وبتسب
الولايات المتحده السعوديه انتاجها اليومي
10 ملايين برميل الخصخصه بمعناها البسيط
هي بيع الشركات الحكوميه لمستثمرين سواء
محليين او دوليين طيب ليه السعوديه بتلج
لهذه المساله لعده اسباب السبب الاول
تهاوي اسعار النفط في العالم نحن كنا
نتحدث عن 114 دولارا للبرميل في منتصف
2014 الان سعر برميل النفط يقل عن 50
دولار وبالتالي يعني ايرادات السعوديه من
النفط تراجعت باكثر من 50% او 60%
الامر الثاني ان السعوديه عليها التزامات
ماليه ضخمه جدا داخليه وخارجيه سواء في
حرب اليمن او غيرها وبالتالي حدث استنزاف
من الاحتياطي سريع السعوديه سحبت خلال
الثلاث سنوات الماضيه 218 مليار دولار من
الاحتياطي النقدي كنا نتحدث عن احتياطي ب
737 الان اقل من 500 مليار دولار الامر
الثالث ان السعوديه لديها عجز مالي في
موازنه هذا العام قدره 51 مليار دولار
وبالتالي من اين ستمول هذا العجز في ظل
استمرار تتحدث هنا عن رؤيه 230 لا هي دي
منفصله انا بتحدث عن المركز المالي كيف
يتم معالجه عجز مالي في الموازنه العام
2017 وبالتالي اما ان تستنزف الاحتياطي
ومزيد من الاحتياطي او تلجا لاساليب اخرى
الاساليب الاخرى التي لجات اليها المملكه
الخصخصه ثم الاقتراض الداخلي والخارجي امس
وزاره الماليه على سبيل المثال اقترضت 51
مليار ريال من السوق المحلي عبر طرح سقوق
لاول مره بالريال ثم اقترضت حوالي 33
مليار دولار في ابريل الماضي وبالتالي من
هنا جاءت الخصخصه لجمع حوالي ترليون جنيه
في العام ل يعني توفير نفقات للموازنه
العامه وتغطيه وتحسين بعض المشروعات او
الخدمات التي سيتم بيعها على المدى القصير
ولا المدى الطوي سنويه الحكومه بتستهدف
جمع لاثه تريليون او ما يعادل 800 مليار
دولار خلال ثلاث سنين بما يعادل ترليون
ريال سعودي خلال السنه طيب نتحول الى لندن
وسيد راان سيد راان هناك رؤيه رؤيه
2030 رؤيه 2030 ويقال بانها تنطوي على ت
تدابير صارمه وتقشف مع الاقتصاد السعودي
الذي تحدث عنه قبل قليل ووضعه الحالي
الاستاذ
مصطفى وهذا بسبب تهاوي اسعار النفط كما
قال كيف يمكن ان تتناسب هذه الرؤيه مع هذا
الوضع الاقتصادي الذي يعيش الاقتصاد
السعودي
الان في طريق من الطرق او في كثير من وجو
ذكر ان صندوق النقد الدولي تحدث عن هذا
الموضوع وهذا يعني بان هناك انخفاض في
مستوى المعيشه رؤيه 20 30 متعلقه باعاده
التعافي للاقتصاد وايجاد توازن اذا يجب ان
يسير بهذا بسرعه لان العجز في
الميزانيه لن يقلص ما لم يكن هناك طرق
لجمع الضرائب الان هم تراجعوا عن بعض
اجراءات التقشف لذلك في المدى القصير هناك
دعم للموازنه من خلال جمع المال ولكن يجب
ان يقوموا باعمال اخرى لاستقطاب راس المال
من خلال بيع الاسهم او الحصص مثل كما هو
الحال في المطارات وما شابه ولكن عليهم ان
يستقطب راس المال وذلك لدعم القطاع الخاص
اي من خلال
الاستثمارات المباشره وليس المحافظ فقط
اذا فال السعوديون لديهم الان فرصه متضا
ايله لذلك عليهم ان يدفعوا قدما باسرع وقت
ممكن من اجل تطبيق هذه الرؤيه 2030 ولكن
قدرتهم على تحقيق ذلك هي تتقلص و بشكل
سريع طيب هنا سؤال يبرز سيد راين ما اهميه
الشفافيه
في وضروره محاربه
الفساد في في مثل هذا التوجه في الوقت
نفسه في الوقت نفسه ا هناك ازمه خليجيه في
في الخليج الان كيف يمكن تشجيع المستثمر
الاجنبي كيف يمكن فعلا الخروج من هذا
المازق عبر فتح الخصخصه امام مستثمرين
اجانب وسط هذا الوضع
الذي تعيشه منطقه
الخليج لاستقطاب الاستثمارات الخارجيه اذا
لم يريدوا بيع هذه الاسهم ف ان الحكومه
واجراءاتها يجب ان تحسن ويجب ان تتوفر
الشفافيه و يجب ان يكون هناك قدره
للمستثمرين ليروا ما هي العمليات الماليه
التي
تتم
بين هذه الشركات التي تخصخص
والحكومه الان عندما تتوفر هذه الشفافيه
سيتحسن الامر والى
ان تتم حل الازمه بين دول الخليج وقطر فلا
ارى ان هناك امكانيه لاستقطاب استثمارات
اجنبيه والسعوديون
بالتالي لن يحصلوا على القدره الدفعيه
التي يتطلعون اليها طيب استاذ مصطفى يعني
واضح بان هناك ازمات سياسيه تعانيها
السعوديه بدء بحرب اليمن انتهاء بازمه
حصار قطر هل فعلا هذه تجعل المستثمر
الاجنبي يتردد كثيرا قبل ضخ اموالي في
الاقتصاد السعودي يعني احنا بنتكلم
المستثمر الاجنبي بينظر لمنطقه الخليج على
انها منطقه واحده وليس السعوديه بمفردها
قطر مفردها الكويت بمفردها وبالتالي اذا
يعني طبقا للتقارير المؤسسات الدوليه بعد
ازمه الخليج او بعد ازمه حصار قطر المخاطر
السياسيه للمنطقه كلها ارتفعت وبالتالي من
هنا يتردد المستثمر الاجنبي في ان ياتي
ولكن يعني السعوديه بتطرح قطاعات جذابه
ممكن ان تجذب كبار المستثمرين بمعنى انها
تطرح حصص في ارامكو على سبيل المثال وهي
طبعا اكبر شركه للنفط في العالم لماذا ب
هناك جدل محلي وعالمي بشان بيع حصص في
ارامكو يعني ارامكو هي رمز يعني تعتبر
اكبر هي رمز الدوله السعوديه يعني اذا كنا
بنتحدى مز ديني
الارامكس اقتصادي نحن نتحدث عن حصه 5%
بتعادل 125 مليار دولار وبالتالي يعني
خصخصه ارامكو سينجم عنها تداعيات حتى على
المواطن بمعنى انها قد يترتب عليها ارتفاع
اسعار البنزين سولار وهكذا يعني يعني
الملاحظ بشكل عام حتى في الخصخصه داخل
المشروعات التي سيتم خصخصتها انها تتعلق
بالمواطن بمعنى سيتم خصخصه المطاحن
والاغذيه المدارس الكهرباء محطات تحليه
المياه وبالتالي هذه قطاعات بتهتم
بالمواطن هذه سيترتب عليها مباشره ارتفاع
اسعار الخد الخدمات والسلع المقدمه
للمواطن العادي استاذ استاذ ريان هل ترى
فعلا بان رؤيه 2030 تضع خط نهايه لدور
الدوله السعوديه التاريخي في تعزيز رفاهيه
المواطن السعودي هل سيصبح المواطن السعودي
مثقل بكثير من الالتزامات المترتبه عليه
جراء عمليات الخصخصه التي ستشهدها قطاعات
كبرى في
السعوديه المشكله
هي انه المواطنون في معظم دول
الخليج نرى ان لديهم اعتماد على اسعار
النفط وقد كان هناك دور كبير للدور
الحكومي في كثير من هذه الدول في الخليج
فالخصم
استشفي وقطاع التعليم ومجالات اخرى قد
يقلص الاسعار بالنظر الى انه في
الماضي كانت تقدم مجانا من ناحيه اخرى
الخصخصه
ستؤدي الى تقليص في الجوده وقد يكون هناك
ارتفاع على المدى القصير في السعر ولكن
القطاع الخاص يجب ان يزيد من دوره اذا ما
الاقتصاد السعودي سوف يعود وينهض ثانيه في
قطاع الطاقه اشكرك ريان ستراكس مدير تحرير
مجله الاقتصاد العالمي المحاضر في
الاقتصاد السلوكي بجامعه بي بي بي في لندن
وكذلك شكرا للاستاذ مصطفى عبد السلام
الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشؤون
الاقتصاديه صواريخ اس 400 روسيه الصنع كيف
تؤثر بمداها وقوتها التدميريه على ميزان
العلاقات الامريكيه التركيه هذا ما نبحثه
في الملف الثالث من الحصاد مع حسن جمول